mich hat heute etwas gefreut
normalerweise bin ich ja dauer empört
aber heute beziehungsweise gestern da
hat mich sehr gefreut und zwar war ich
auf dem gipfel der jungunternehmer in
berlin und da hat armin laschet ein
grußwort an die unternehmer gerichtet
und dass wir dort gesprochen hat und was
es für ein klares bekenntnis war zur fdp
das hat mich gefreut haben wir mal rein
auf die nächsten tage kommt es an wir
haben die chance eine bürgerliche
regierung mit
der cdu und einem neuen kanzler in gang
zu setzen ich will bundeskanzler werden
will dass in einer koalition mit starken
liberalen möglich machen
damit hat armin laschet ganz klar farbe
bekannt und zwar dass er mit der fdp
koalieren will dass er nicht in eine
linke regierung will und ich fand das
wichtig und vor allem auch richtig denn
in letzter zeit kam es mir so vor als
will eigentlich kein politiker mehr
irgendetwas ausschließen johannes vogel
war zum beispiel kurz vorher auf der
bühne gestern auch bei dem gipfeltreffen
hat doch gesagt naja wenn jetzt etwas
ausschließen würde dass wir jetzt auch
gerade nicht so klug war alle anderen
das ja auch nicht tun ich finde dass
armin laschet bei diesen grußwort an die
jungen unternehmer ganz klar gesagt hat
ich will die fdp an meiner seite ich
will mit christian lindner auch auf
bundesebene koalieren und ich finde es
wichtig weil im gegensatz zu kevin kühn
hat der die ausschließeritis ja schon
seit wochen anprangert finde ich es gut
wenn politiker harte kante zeigen und
sagen mit dem sie am liebsten koalieren
würden und vor allem was sie nicht
wollen mich hat das grußwort gestern
gefreut in einer zeit in der eigentlich
kaum noch ein politiker sagt was er
eigentlich am liebsten will ich meine
unabschätzbare hat ja gerade sowohl eine
fdp als auch an den
grünen aber haben die lasche kann ja
viel wollen aber was dann am ende kann
ist doch die große frage alexander gerst
naja was ist das geschäft ist ich will
ich will natürlich ich will auch viel
aber wenn armin laschet dann am ende nur
die möglichkeit hat mit der spd und wie
man auch immer eine koalition zu formen
dann macht er dass er zwar nicht
ausgeschlossen dort und gleichzeitig
finde ich ist es momentan ein dermaßen
desaster man wundert sich ja noch dass
er überhaupt den satz gerade raus
bekommen ich will bundeskanzler werden
ja auch das vergisst man mittlerweile
schon an zwar kam es heute morgen hat er
beim aussteigen als er den
wahlkampfterminen und bayern hatte erst
mal gesagt als erster satz ich habe mir
die brille richten lassen also
entschuldige bitte ja also das ist nicht
was ich von einem künftigen
bundeskanzler erwarte der das werden
will dass er sich nicht mal einsatz
vorbereitet hat und das ist exemplarisch
für für seinen auftritt was armin
laschet denn man weiß nicht was er will
man weiß nicht wo das hinführen soll und
man sieht dass eine spd die ja die so am
abgrund war dass dies überhaupt schaffen
auf dem level zu bleiben also eine
aufholjagd sieht wie es nicht anders aus
als jetzt einen punkt gewonnen noch mal
und das nach den vielen schlagzeilen
armin laschet immer noch dasteht ist ein
absolutes desaster für die union ja
außerdem
nach einer interpretation hätte ja auch
dann
olaf scholz
alles andere ausgeschlossen weil er
gerne eine koalition mit den grünen
machen würde aber auch gesagt würde
gerne mit den grünen koalieren reich
bloß nicht es reicht bei dem genauso
wenig wie es bei laschet reichen ich
kann das unterlassen unterschied nee nee
und laschet finde ich nicht überlegung
und lasse das war eben groß vor ort ja
es war keine grundsatzrede
grußworte die kennt man und er sagt ja
er hat ja ausdrücklich nicht mal
ausgeschlossen dass er noch mal eine
große koalition geht und zwar als
juniorpartner na das ist ja schon sehr
das wäre sehr demütigend ich hoffe nicht
dass es dazu kommt also hat eigentlich
gar nichts ausgeschlossen wir wissen
doch eher linke ausgeschlossen dass
berba kunz möchte das ist das jetzt
schon
die wahl mal von hinten her ganz einfach
zu beschreiben es gibt zwei parteien von
denen wir sich ziemlich sicher sein
können dass sie regieren sind die grünen
und der fdp und jetzt geht es noch darum
wer mit den beiden regiert ist es die
spd oder die union und das sieht im
moment für die spd einfacher aus und ich
bin mir zwar zu 98 prozent sicher dass
die linke dieses land nicht regieren
wird und wenn man der spd nicht glaubt
dann sollte man die grünen sie haben
einmal gesagt schrieben ihre prognosen
seien meistens falsch 1 98% glaube ich
nicht gesagt ich habe da wo ich mich
geirrt habe und da habe ich mich aber
mit der gesamten führung der cdu geht
dort war dass sie angenommen habe dass
merkel zwei jahre früher vor ablauf
ihrer amtszeit geht das hätte sie mal
tun sollen da wäre der cdu viel erspart
worden und dem land übrigens auch wenn
es vorher machtwechsel gegeben hat aber
dass diese bescheidene frau durchhält
bis zum letzten tag das hat habe ich
nicht erwartet die drei scheinen ja ja
ich glaube die große koalition ist nicht
mehr in großer koalition das heißt es
wird auch nicht alleine große koalition
die große koalition wird nicht nur für
die cdu sondern das ganze land ein
desaster wir haben ja gesehen was das
eigentlich auch bei uns mit unserer
diskus kultur mit der themen die da
gesetzt werden und mit der
radikalisierung die wir in unserer
gesellschaft gehabt haben und drittens
auch wenn die linke nicht mitregiert die
wert auch durch die spd mit regiert auch
kräfte da sind nicht weit ideologisch
von das was die linke partei heute an so
das stimmt man sollte deshalb nach der
wahl das projekt vorantreiben falls die
spd nicht den kanzler stellt sollte sie
endlich die linke auffressen und mit ihm
fusionieren damit das theater ein ende
hat die linke ist sowieso keine
sozialistische partei mehr kleinere
elemente ist eine links
sozialdemokratische partei und die spd
sagt ja zu recht die programme von
linker und spd und unterscheiden sich
kaum noch wozu brauchen wir überhaupt
die linke sehr unterscheidet sich schon
damit ob man zum beispiel mitglied der
nato sein wäre ja ob man irgendwie nach
russland fährt lang haben die hände
schüttelt gut dass wir wohl auf scholz'
oder andere lasse dann auch machen oder
ein kuba ist also dann gibt's ja vieles
naja aber mindestlohn und und
steuerpolitik und substantive sind die
völlig identisch fast auch nicht mehr
viel zu verhandeln also die sind deshalb
sollte man sie auffressen damit die kuba
und und senator und diese anderen punkte
wegfallen und das wäre eine bereinigung
das wieder vielleicht paar größere
parteien entstehen ja denn wenn die
union wieder mal stärker wird und eine
andere partei auffrisst in den
verkraftbaren elementen wäre nicht
schlecht sind wieder hochinteressant wie
die deutsche politik von den insidern
diskutiert wird und ich komme jetzt
damit meinem dilettantischen außen blick
was dich sagen ansonsten wieder
kokettiert
schön bescheiden bleiben
ich meine es wäre natürlich gut wenn die
cdu tatsächlich mit der fdp eine
regierung bilden könnte aus meiner sicht
ich fand das toll ich fände das wie
deutschland sei auf knapp 30 jahre aber
ich habe damals als ich noch bei der
welt gearbeitet habe einmal einen
leitartikel geschrieben vor den wahlen
das ich sei für eine regierung cdu/fdp
worauf mich herr steinbrück zur brust
genommen hat er gesagt sie sind ja in
deutschland gar nicht wahlberechtigt
oder das erkennen der mag ja auch keine
schweizerin und ja das wusste ich damals
noch nicht darf ich sehr haben sie nicht
objektiv beurteilen aber in der
deutschen politik so viel habe ich
entstanden ist ja eigentlich als
spitzenkandidat darfst du eigentlich
keine option ausschließen also ich würde
doch etwas dem herrn runzheimer seine
interpretation teilen laschet versucht
sich natürlich in allen lagen irgendwie
kompatibel zu zeigen und das finde ich
auch eine eigenheit in der deutschen
politik dass wir sehen jetzt immer diese
duelle trelle und da preisen sich diese
kandidaten an und die leute glauben dann
aber interessant da viele stars der wm
stars aber die entscheidende frage gehen
die deutsche politik ist mit wem machen
die eine koalition unter umständen ist
dann dort wo lasche draufsteht gar nicht
löschen weil sie schon ziemlich
schwierig ist herauszufinden was drin
ist hat natürlich grund sei man recht
oder wenn sie eine chance haben wenn die
natürlich mit rot-rot-grün regiert ist
ein ganz anderes als wenn der vielleicht
mit einer anderen konstellation regiert
ist sowieso für mich etwas ein
trojanisches weil er natürlich eine
partei hat die ihn gar nicht will dass
er eine ganz absonderliche konstellation
ist also ich würde das nicht aus ein
ausschluss statement werten von von
laschet das ist ein wunsch ich würde den
teilen ich finde den gut aber das
interessante ist eigentlich dass die
frage der koalition alles dominiert und
ich habe man bei frau merkel die analyse
gemacht alle wahlversprechen von 2005
die sie gemacht hat von denen viele
übrigens gut worden keins von den
wirklich gar keins konnte sie einhalten
aufgrund der koalition in den sinn wenn
wir mal was es ist eine wundertüte die
deutsche politik ist die groß dem grill
wundertüte diese war wenn wir mal
betrachten wie oft verschenkt wie oft
wir schon stürmisch digitalisiert worden
sind müssen in der weltspitze legen sind
aber auf platz 34 von 38 die
hauptschulen 5 und wie häufig schon
steuern gesehen daher sollen immer
wieder die dann nach der wahl nicht mehr
gesund werden und das finde ich eine
ganz interessante frage werden über den
koalitionen sind also erstmal glaube ich
armin laschet ist so verzweifelt weil er
weiß wenn er das nicht überlebt dann
wird es auch nicht mal mehr überleben
ministerpräsident von
nordrhein-westfalen zu sehr schafft kann
wird in nordrhein westfalen ein
großes ein grosser umsturz stattfinden
das wird er nicht schaffen das heißt es
so verzweifelt dass am ende sogar
versuchen wird vize kanzler zu werden
das werden ihnen aber glaube ich die
leute in der union nicht erlauben die
jetzt schon in den hintergründen erlös
der über den ich sie hören dass
wahrscheinlich auch dass da ja schon
längst drüber gesprochen hat wirklich
wer wird denn jetzt fraktionschef wenn
wir so ablösen die wahnsinnig der
unicredit ich hier je erlebt habe einen
wahlkampf das wird tatsächlich zwar
einen hofstaat die spd gesagt wir wollen
ein prozent mehrwertsteuererhöhung und
die cdu hat gesagt zwei prozent oder 0
prozent als einfach nicht angesagt 1 und
2 dann kann auf sechs wichtige
koalitionsverhandlungen haben sich auf
einen kompromiss geeinigt drei prozent
gab das habe ich immer gesagt bei
koalitionsverhandlungen wird teuer für
den deutschen münchen auch mathematisch
deutschland europa und das ist noch die
große frage wirtschaft christian lindner
da ist jetzt am ende bei einer möglichen
ampel zu sagen ich krieg das durch das
steuern irgendwie gesenkt werden wenn
die anderen beiden parteien in dem fall
der spd die grünen tragen das kriegt er
nicht durch aber er kriegt durch das ihn
nicht erhöht werden bättig andrist doch
das ist seine lebensversicherung wenn er
das nicht durchhält ist die fdp vier
jahres ich sehe er tot
hoffnungen er hat seine hoffnungen und
nicht aufgegeben dass die deutschen
politiker ein
lebensjahr ja eigentlich etwas gegen
diese lasche zerstörungen hier am tisch
unternehmen aber meine redezeit ist
leider vorbei jeder von euch hat sich
doch gezeigt es gibt noch menschen in
deutschland die laschet ernst nehmen und
ihnen mögen
wort für wort ernst nicht für
menschliche er hat wirklich alles getan
an diesem tag um die jungunternehmer für
sich zu gewinnen und was wollen die
höheren eine entwarnung unternehmen auf
mich hat er in dem thriller
autoren aber ich bin kein junge
unternehmen
[Musik]